our cell is like a factory now inside
the factory there are several machine
producing its product and this product
is going to the market and market has a
certain demand according to which these
machines are producing its product now
inside of the cell
also there are necessity of proteins in
order to sustain that developmental the
growth and also the physiological
processes of a cell so that's why all
the time DNA is going to RNA and RNA
from RNA protein is made now in this
process from DNA to RNA to protein the
need is variable sometimes cell require
one protein more than the other so all
these processes of DNA to RNA or RNA to
protein could be regulated as per demand
and that's why regulation of
transcription and translation processes
are so important to understand in this
video we would talk about
transcriptional regulation just like a
fan has its own regulator and turning
the regulator we can change the fan
speed a transcriptional machinery that
means from DNA to producing mRNA also
has regulatory mechanisms some
regulatory mechanisms are trans
regulatory mechanisms which are protein
based or based on transcription factor
binding and some are mediated by six
regulatory elements which are also
present in the DNA nearby the gene or
far away from the gene and I'm going to
talk about those C's regulatory elements
in this video and how they regulate
transcription now here is a typical
simplified diagram of a gene where
yellow is the gene body and now the
first regulatory element to talk about
is a promoter now promoter is a short
regulatory sequence just near to the
gene body either at the stand and where
the RNA is polymer RNA polymerase to
bind and transcription initiation happen
for transcription to initiate at least a
minimal promoter should be there
apart from promoter there are other see
winces known as enhancers enhancers
could be both side of the gene either
upstream or downstream but they could be
like as far away as in order of three
four kilo base pairs and still they can
regulate the gene expression from a
particular gene promoter and from the
from the gene body so how does enhancers
work actually the general transcription
factors of tf2d family binds to the
promoter the minimal promoter and
recruits poly to in that promoter now
upstream enhancer elements bind to
specialized transcription factor
specialized transcription factor can
interact with cofactors now these
cofactors could be either co-repressor
or some cases these factors could be
co-activators if it's a co-activator
these upstream enhancer sequence
undergoes our DNA folding mechanism such
that these cofactors and specialized
transcription factor can interact with
this pole to complex and thereby
regulate the frequency of translation or
how frequent our house what is the speed
of the transcription would happen now
inside of the cell the DNA is not free
so DNA is in form of a nucleosome
arrangement so here I'm showing a gene X
and 2 enhancer of it gene a and gene B
even though gene B is pretty far away
from this particular gene X enhancer a
and in answer B both of them has certain
amount of influence on the expression of
gene X now I need to show you guys the
different chromatin states of an
enhancer enhancer is active when the
enhancer is accessible to specialized
transcription factors that means the
nucleosome is somehow translocated away
from that end region in answer region
now it could be also primed enhancer
where the enhancer is accessible but not
the transcription factors the
specialized transcription factors are
just not bound it could be also poised
that could be opened or closed so
bi-directional markers are there on in
this stage but exactly they are not
accessible to the transcription factor
right now but they could be modified in
near future depend depending upon the
need of the cell now different enhancers
could influence the gene in a
differential manner depending upon which
tissue they are present at for example
inside a neuron let's say there are
there is an expression of gene X and in
gene X is very important for survival of
the neuron so gene X is modulated by the
enhancer a here but not by enhancer B
but let's say we consider another cell
intestinal cell and here we see a
different scenario enhancer a and
enhancer be both regulate the expression
from gene X so depending upon the tissue
the enhancers that regulate the
transcription could be also different
and that leads to the heterogeneity of
gene expression in artists and in
different tissues so have you ever
wondered that how to identify this
enhancer sequence now if you know a
certain transcription factor that binds
to this enhancer region then definitely
you can pull down that pull down that
with an antibody and then sequence the
region where it points that would give
you the enhancer sequence otherwise
there are many other approaches
bioinformatic approaches histone
modification seeks chromosome
conformation capture based approaches
and DNA's seek all these things are
there to find the enhancer sequences now
how to understand that one enhancer is
active and one enhancer is inactive or
closed state so in an open state there
are specific
marks on the enhancer that tells us that
it's in an open state which is very
different from the marks present in a
closed state so if you even look at the
different histone modifications in a
chromatin region which is a putative
enhancer then we can understand ok the
enhancer is there but what physiological
state is it in is it an open state
enhancer or is it in a closed state so
in a flow state enhancer does not
influence the gene expression from the
nearby promoter so that's why it's
interesting to understand the open state
and the closed state of a chromatin in
my other videos I will be talking about
enhancers in lot more details so this is
a basic overview of enhancers so if you
liked my video give it a quick thumbs up
and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you